>> WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IT'S CLEAR BOTH OF THE COUNTRY'S
POLITICAL PARTIES ARE HAVE
CHANGED RADICALLY.
THEY ARE CHANGING STILL.
WE COVERED THAT EVERY NIGHT ON
THE SHOW.
DONALD TRUMP IS TRANSFORMED THE
GOP, YOU MAY HAVE READ ABOUT IT.
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, THERE
HAVE BEEN PROFOUND CHANGES TOO.
ONES THAT DON'T GET AS MUCH
ATTENTION.
PARTY FOR HUNDRED YEARS STOOD
WITH AMERICA'S MIDDLE CLASS NOW
REPRESENTS THE NATION'S RICHEST
AND POOREST.
THE PARTY POSITION ON POLICY
HAVE CHANGED ACCORDINGLY.
A LOT.
THIS IS ABOUT 20 YEARS AGO,
DEMOCRATS CHAMPION FREE SPEECH.
THEY WORRIED ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, LOUDLY.
THEY CRITICIZED VOLUNTARY
FOREIGN WARS AND THEY ARGUED
UNRESTRICTED TRADE HURT AMERICAN
WORKERS.
BY THE WAY, QUITE A FEW OF THEM,
DEMOCRATS WERE PRO-LIFE TOO.
SENATOR HARRY REID AMONG THEM.
THAT'S NOT SURPRISING.
DEMOCRATS SAID THEY CARED MOST
ABOUT THE VULNERABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY.
EVEN BILL CLINTON WHO VETOED
PARTIAL ABORTION BAN HE WANTED
TO KEEP ABORTION RARE.
HE SAID THAT A LOT.
TRY THAT IN TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY PUT IT ON T-SHIRTS.
ABORTION ISN'T BAD.
WE NEED MORE OF IT.
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO SIGNED A
BILL MAKING THAT POSSIBLE.
IT'S CALLED THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH ACT.
THE LAW LEGALIZES ABORTION RIGHT
TO THE MOMENT OF BIRTH FOR ANY
REASON.
TO MOST PEOPLE, ABORTING A CHILD
MOMENT BEFORE DELIVERY MIGHT
SEEM UNCOMFORTABLY LIKE KILLING.
IT'S A CONCERN.
CUOMO'S LAW ADDRESSES THAT
CONCERN.
LAW DECLARES CHILDREN WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN YET BORN ARE NOT IN
FACT HUMAN.
HE DESCRIBED IT IS A PROFOUND
MORAL VICTORY.
THE NATIONAL PRESS DIDN'T SPEND
TIME COVERING THIS.
THERE'S STILL SOMETHING PRETTY
GHOULISH ABOUT CELEBRATING
THIRD-TERM ABORTION.
THAT'S WHY ONLY TINY OF
PERCENTAGE AMERICAN VOTERS
SUPPORT IT.
NOBODY REALLY WANTS TO HEAR THE
DETAILS ABOUT THIS.
NOBODY ASKS.
THAT'S WHY THE VIDEO WE'RE ABOUT
TO SHOW YOU, IT IS REMARKABLE.
IN IT A AVOIDS DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER CALLED KATHY TRANT,
EXPLAINED IN DETAIL A BILL SHE'S
INTRODUCED THAT WILL REMOVE ALL
RESTRICTION ON LATE-TERM
ABORTION.
SHE WAS ASKED WHAT WOULD THAT
MEAN AND TRANS TELLS THE TRUTH.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHERE IT'S OBVIOUS THAT A
WOMAN WITH TO GIVE BIRTH, SHE'S
HAS PHYSICAL SIGN ABOUT TO GIVE
BIRTH.
WOULD THAT STILL BE POINT SHE
CAN REQUEST AN ABORTION IF SHE
WAS CERTIFIED?
SHE'S DIELATING.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN,ING THAT WOULD
BE A DECISION THAT THE DOCTOR,
THE PHYSICIAN AND THE WOMAN --
>> I'M ASKING IF YOUR BILL
ALLOWS THAT.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: SO, ABORTION AT THE
POINT OF DILATION.
IF YOU KUDED -- ACCUSED WHAT IN
MEAN, ASK EVERYONE WHO IS GIVING
BIRTH.
YOU MAYBE PRO-CHOICE, ARE YOU
OKAY WITH THAT?
VIRGINIA'S GOVERNOR IS OKAY WITH
THAT.
HE THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
HE'S BEEN IN OFFICE LITTLE OVER
A YEAR.
HE'S ALWAYS DESCRIBED AS
MODERATE.
THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING GIVEN HIS
REACTION TO KATHY TRAN'S
ABORTION BILL.
>> IT'S DONE IN CASES WHERE
THERE MAYBE SEER DEFORMITIES.
THERE MAYBE A FETUS.
IN THIS PARTICULAR EXAMPLE, IF A
MOTHER IS IN LABOR, I CAN TELL
YOU EXACTLY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
THE INFANT WILL BE DELIVERED.
THE INFANT WILL BE KEPT
COMFORTABLE.
THE INFANT WILL BE RESUSCITATED
IF THAT'S WHAT THE MOTHER AND
FAMILY DESIRE.
THEN A DISCUSSION WOULD ENSUE
BETWEEN THE PHYSICIANS AND THE
MOTHER.
>> A DISCUSSION ABOUT KILLING
THE INFANT?
THE INFANT.
HE'S DIRECTING -- THE INFANT
WILL BE DELIVERED AND
RESUSCITATED IF THAT'S WHAT THE
MOTHER DESIRES.
QUOTE, IN OTHER WORDS, THE
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA JUST TOLD
US IN PUBLIC ON CAMERA THAT IT'S
OKAY TO KILL A CHILD AFTER THE
CHILD HAS BEEN BORN.
THAT USED TO BE CALL INFANT
INFANTICIDE.
TAKING THE LIFE OF A CHILD WHO
IS BREATHING.
THE GOVERNOR SEEM TO SAY THAT.
DID HE MISSPEAK?
YOU'D HOPE.
HE DIDN'T.
RALPH NORTHAM IS A PHYSICIAN.
HE'S NOT SOME CLUELESS LAYMAN
WHO MANGLED A TALKING POINT.
THIS IS WHAT HE THINKS.
THIS IS WHAT HIS PARTY THINKS.
NO ONE EVER SAYS IT, BUT IT'S